[Générique]
Mademoiselle!
Un p'tit selfie?
Abonne-toi !
T'es là, toi.
Hein ?
Toi au moins tu m'écoutes.
Tu sais que dans le temps, je faisais des vidéos à dix millions de vues?
Ouais !
Salut mes petites tartelettes !
Alors, euh... là, dernièrement, il y a un petit film qui est sorti, je sais pas si vous en avez entendu parler...
STAR WARS !
Luke, je suis ton père.
Euh... Mais du coup, si t'es mon père, je peux avoir la Playstation 4 ?
Je postais une photo et tout le monde likait.
J'avais tellement d'amis sur Facebook que je refusais du monde.
J'avais plein de fans !
JOJO, JOJO, JOJO !
J'étais ami avec tous les plus grands de Youtube.
Et puis un jour il est arrivé.
Jacky l'agrume.
Avec sa putain de tête d'intellectuel.
Et son physique de coton-tige.
Salut à tous, je suis super content de vous retrouver
Aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un truc, c'est les rêves bizarres.
Je sais pas vous, moi j'en fais tout le temps.
Pas plus tard qu'hier j'ai rêvé d'une armée de canards avec Jack Sparrow et Barack Obama qui étaient dans ma chambre.
Jamais rien bité de ce qu'il racontait
En une vidéo, tout le monde l'a adoré.
Jacky !? Jacky l'agrume?
Ouais, ouais c'est moi.
Ben regarde. Je suis trop fan de ce que tu fais, je connais toutes tes vidéos.
Ah, ça fait super plaisir !
-Est-ce que tu peux me dédicacer mon t-shirt s'il-te plaît? -Ouais, ouais t'inquiète pas. -C'est génial!
Je suis tellement fan de tes vidéos, je les connais toutes par coeur, c'est....
Je supportais pas son succès ça me rendait fou.
Salut mes petites tartelettes, hey Jacky l'agrume ça serait pas un petit peu nul ?
Totalement, c'est haaaaaaaaalucinant comme c'est nul. Bitch.
Je me suis mis à perdre les pédales.
Je me suis enfoncé.
Ouaiiis, salut les petites tartelettes de merde ! Hé ouais, je vous chie à la gueule tous autant que vous êtes.
Puis si vous êtes pas contents, vous avez qu'à vous faire tartiner le cul par Jacky l'agrume. Ok !
Parce que vous savez ce que c'est ?
C'est un EN-CU-LÉ !
Après ça j'ai commencé à me prendre des pouces rouges dans la vraie vie.
À commencer par ma copine.
Mais tu te fous de ma gueule ? C'est quoi ce bordel !?
- On n'a plus une thune Jonathan !
- Quoi ? Tu veux que je fasse quoi ? Que je fasse le guignol ?
_ Mais tu fais ce que tu veux, connard !
- Je suis un artiste !
Va faire l'artiste ailleurs, dégage!
Mais tu sais ce que c'est le plus dur ?
Le plus dur...
C'est d'être regardé...
...Sans jamais être vu
Oh, t'es là mon petit buzz d'amour !
Oh, ça me fait plaisir de te voir !
Comment tu te sens aujourd'hui mon Jojo?
Oh, pas très fort, tu sais.
Monsieur !
Un p'tit partage?
Non ? Pas grave, bonne journée.
Ça fait combien de temps que tu  t'es pas connecté Jojo?
Oh, je sais plus... Trois jours peut être?
Ils m'ont donné 10 lignes dans un skyblog
Mais le topic c'était "Comment faire un rond de serviette ?"
Alors je ne vais pas aller bien loin avec ça
Mademoiselle !
Z'auriez pas un pouce?
Un p'tit RT, un p'tit fav, un p'tit coeur !
Je suis fatigué.
J'en peux plus.
Tu connaitrais pas un endroit où on pourrait m'héberger?
Calme toi, mon Jojo, calme toi. Je vais voir ce que je peux faire
Malheureusement j'ai pas grand chose en ce moment... Ah!
J'ai un compte LinkedIn
Oh non non, je ne touche pas à ça moi
Mais sinon, un petit selfie?
Ah ouais!
Ouais un selfie c'est bien, ça va me faire du bien, ça
Voilà... Allez
Je te laisse
Prend soin de toi, mon Jojo!
Merci mon petit oiseau
Et oublie pas de me taguer, hein!
T'en fais pas, Jojo!
Parce que les gens ils oublient, souvent.
Oh!
Hein? Quoi?
Vous êtes bien Jojo fait le zozo?
Comment tu connais mon nom, toi?
J'étais fan de vous! C'est grâce à vous si je fais des vidéos aujourd'hui !
Plus personne n'est fan de moi aujourd'hui... Y a plus de Jojo, c'est fini tout ça.
Aujourd'hui c'est clodo !
Clodo fait le zozo.
Allez, partage et abonne-toi ou passe ton chemin.
Attendez. Je vais vous montrer un truc.
Regardez.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux que j'en foute ?
Retourne le peut-être. Voilà.
J'ai combien d'abonnés, d'après vous ?
Toi ? Trois millions minimum.
-Non, non...
-Plus ?
-Non non ... Beaucoup moins
J'ai trois mille abonnés.
Allez.
Bon courage, Jojo.
Tu lâches mon téléphone, s'il-te-plaît ?
Lâche ça.
Tu lâches ! Merci.
Saaalut, mes petites tartelettes !
Vous avez déjà pris le métro ?
Non, parce que moi y'a deux trois trucs qui m'énervent un p'tit peu !
Les odeurs ! Non mais sérieux, faut faire deux mètres pour que ça sente bon ?
[Quelques petits rires]
Je voulais vous dire merci parce que vous êtes déjà douze à regarder ce que je fais
et ça, ça ça met du chauffage au palpitant
ça fait vraiment plaisir et ça m'donne envie de continuer,
alors merci, merci beaucoup.
La voix dans le métro !
Non mais sérieux, elle répète tout deux fois : "Saint-Lazare ... Saint-Lazare."
[Musique qui recouvre les paroles]
[Acclamations] Jojo ! Jojo ! Jojo ! Jojo ! ...